hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we're doing an ask IJ episode
that's where you guys ask me questions I
usually ask you on twitter using the
hashtag s IJ and I was actually shocked
being obviously a huge iPhone Apple fan
you guys are super obsessed with me
using Android phones I saw so many
questions asking me from getting s 9
what current Android phone am i using
and first I'm going to answer the
question of what Android phone am I
currently using right now right now I am
currently using the pixel to when I was
traveling I wanted to bring my Google
phone along mostly because I really love
the front-facing portrait mode but
before that I was using the 1 + 5 t in
sandstone this phone is beautiful when I
think about what a perfect phone looks
like this is it
I love the look of this I love the
placement of the fingerprint sensor it's
so slick and beautiful I mean it just
fits right in at home with my little
shooting setup here and before that I
was using the note 8 and then before
that I was using the S 8 leading in to
the question of Justine are you going to
get an S 9 which is what all of you guys
wanted to know there are so many s 9
questions I was like what we need to
talk about it that's gonna be the first
question that we address and yes I am
going to get an S 9 and I'm kind of
excited about it because I love the dual
aperture one of the things that's really
difficult with smartphones is taking
photos in low light so with the dual
aperture depending upon what lighting
situation you'll be in it will adjust
accordingly so I cannot wait to go and
try and take some night photos and see
how this thing stands up I'm also kind
of excited about the AR emojis that they
have much like the ant emojis on the
iPhone you can take a selfie with the
samsung s 9 and it will create an
augmented reality version of yourself so
you will look something similar to this
so I'm really excited to see what my a R
emoji looks like will it look like me
will it not I'm not sure I've seen so
many of my friends posting their AR
emojis so I can't wait to see what mine
looks like it has new intelligent scans
so it's using facial recognition and
iris scanning so it supposedly will help
you be able to unlock your phone quicker
in the dark also I'm excited about the
live translation when I was in Austria
recently I just it's crazy because
everybody else outside of the US speaks
English thankfully because on
Americans we barely know one language so
it's really unfortunate traveling abroad
because I usually don't know what signs
say so I was using Google Translate on
my iPhone
all those live translations it will
happen super super fast
so in f/8 one of the biggest complaints
I think a lot of people had was the
fingerprint sensor was off-centered so
they now have moved it a little bit
lower right below the camera so it's
nice and centered depending upon which
fingerprint you have it'll be easier to
access as for which color I definitely
want to get a lilac one and mostly
because it's different than any other
phone that I have so what I saw that
that was one of the color choices I just
had to do it
I'll be posting that review very shortly
so stay tuned if you guys aren't
subscribed make sure you subscribe so
you don't miss it moving along from the
s9 questions we have got well you're
probably gonna ask just see what is on
your phone right now I went to the Grand
Canyon recently and I think that when I
posted that vlog YouTube was broken
because nobody saw it you didn't get in
your subscriptions so if you want to see
that I will put an annotation here and a
link in the description if you want to
watch it
we rode mules around the Grand Canyon
and one of the things that we had to do
we had to have our phones attached to
ourselves
so I took this GoPro strap that was from
one of the GoPro floating devices and I
attached it to my tech 21 case so it's
kind of not really that sturdy but I've
had it on here for several weeks and now
I'm addicted like I don't want to use my
phone without a strap on it that's a
question that has been asked before but
not in the ask IJ hashtag carbon is
asking would you drive this uh well I
don't know if my audio can fit in that
but I do have many Lego versions of
myself that couldn't so yes
Lego just seems definitely wood Magus is
asking what camera rig to use for
vlogging the short answer is for the
point-and-shoot camera I used as an
rx100 mark 5 but for on-the-go better
audio lenses I use the a 6500 what do I
do with all the Apple stickers that come
with everything that I've bought over
the years it's actually a really good
question I wish that I would have saved
them but sometimes they get thrown away
sometimes they just stay in the box
other times I stick them to things but
most the time I feel like they do get
misplaced but that would have been the
coolest thing ever if I had saved all of
those from the very beginning of buying
Apple products I really messed up Taron
is asking me if I still edit my own
videos yes I do I'm crazy it really
wanted to try to double the amount of
content that I do this year but it's
really hard because I do need to find an
editor and I know so many of you guys
have offered to edit for me but I'm so
picky and I'm so silly and I just feel
like at some point I just wanted to do
it myself maybe I'm a control freak I'm
not sure I usually don't think of myself
as one but when it comes to editing and
creating my content I'm like I know
exactly what I want let me just do it
Deb is asking can I play the drums I did
play drums actually in high school a
little bit but I wasn't very good I
didn't know what I was doing I would
just be like oh this sounds cool I'm
gonna play this I also don't know how to
read music I feel like it's probably
something that I could easily learn but
do I want to learn I don't think so
maybe one day I'm gonna be the next
drummer in some random band and you're
gonna believe I remember what she made
yes on YouTube and now she's the drummer
and insert band name here Deb is also
asking what audible book recommendation
I've been listening to surprise time for
the audible plug but this is actually
very exciting because I didn't even know
that you could do this until I recently
found out you can listen to audible
books on your echo devices now I'm not
gonna say her name
al exa a lot of you guys have been very
upset because I've been triggering your
smart-home devices so I'm going to bleep
every time I say her name if you guys
have never used audible before I
definitely recommend it I use it all the
time when I'm traveling or in traffic to
pass the time you guys can get one month
free trial plus a free audiobook check
out audible.com slash iJustine or text
iJustine to 500 500 but this is where it
gets good because if you've got one of
these little guys i unbox this not too
long ago this is the echo spot I also
have an echo show downstairs in my
kitchen you can listen to your audible
books on your Amazon echo devices and
not only that you won't lose your place
if you decide to go from the echo device
to your phone back to the device again
you can pause you can rewind you can set
a timer let's try it out play my audio
book getting your book from audible
resuming I just teen of every text
message data transfer and file
download I've made since switching
service providers why in the world would
they send me this pause okay so I paused
it on there
and now I'm gonna open up my audible app
and here it is it picks up right where I
left off on the echo device I know I've
done a ton of these audible plugs before
but this is probably the most exciting
because this is the first time that I've
listened to my own audiobooks one of
those things where you do something and
you record it and you're just afraid
that it's not gonna be what you expect
it to be because I have no control over
what it was so I was like I'm just never
gonna listen to it so this is several
years later and this is the first time
that I'm listening to it and it's
actually really really cool I'm kind of
getting a little bit emotional now
because this book meant so much to me
and it really kind of told my story of
how I got started and why I'm standing
here today I'm standing by the way I'm
not sitting down so spoiler alert so you
haven't got this book I would love for
you to listen to it or read it again
check out audible.com slash iJustine and
if you guys have already read my book
thank you so much if you've listened to
it that's even more amazing because you
get to hear me read my book to you and
this is so crazy
it's kind of crazy because I released
this book in 2015 and has already been
several years since so I feel like you
know telling the story of my life it
stops at a certain point so now I feel
like how much time will pass before I
write the second one I really did enjoy
the whole writing process I feel like
because it was my first book I didn't
really know what I was doing you tubers
weren't really releasing books like they
are now I learned so much in that
process so I definitely look forward to
hopefully doing another one in the
future I have a bunch of fun ideas not
just an autobiography but a few other
things that I think you guys would enjoy
well thank you guys for watching I enjoy
reading all of your questions which
mostly were revolving around am I
getting an s9 do you guys have any other
questions I will be answering those in
the comments below for the next few
hours of this video and usually the next
couple of days I come back and forth and
read and reply if you have any other
questions leave in the comments and I
will see you in my next video
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]